i've got my opener on the road with me
dan carney i got up he got upset with me
uh
uh last night because i i was going in
on
sports journalists and i was suggesting
that people like jamelli hill
weren't geniuses really funny i was it's
sports it's
it's what what are we doing it's there
are smart people that are athletes
let's get this out of the way for all of
you that are angry at me and go oh tim
you're fat and you're not an athlete
that's why you're gonna do blah
no no i am an athlete i'll beat you in a
swim race
i was a great athlete third fastest
butterflyer on long island at seven
years old that counts
that kid doesn't matter i'm fat now it
counts then i was winning then
you've never won but a journalist who
covers basketball
is not an intelligent human being enough
they're not bright it's what it is
most journalists who cover politics
aren't bright there's like five of them
that i respect
but let's stop but but here's the
problem this little guy who i love he's
great
but he you know he had like a basketball
podcast you know what they do is they
get
the kit you can't tell you can't tell
anyone under 30 right now that they're
not the greatest thing to
have existed on earth because they think
it's abuse
they stare at you like you're abusing
them if you tell them that they are not
the you know the reincarnation of jesus
christ on the planet
so when when he goes when so he
everybody likes things they could talk
with authority about
sure you know what i mean people like
the things they can speak with authority
about
uh so when i was uh denigrating
people to talk about sports
professionally for money
he got a little mad at me because he's
got you know he had a basketball
podcast with his very attractive friend
i used to tune in every now and then
because
the friend is like insanely attractive
and then you know of course there's the
one that i
usually spend time with but they're just
not
i mean sports are important we need them
as a country they're good i'm all for
that competition blah blah blah i'm with
it all
and there's some very smart people that
are coaches and i get that
but when you talk about the people that
are our sports journalists
i mean i don't know how many real
geniuses you have in that crew
am i is that controversial statement i
don't think so are people getting angry
at me
i like bob costas he's kind of he's
pretty
smart yeah brian gumbel i mean i'm not
saying there aren't there aren't smart
people outside
yeah bill bill simmons yeah there's a
lot of smart bit but
but by and large on the whole let's
cut it out what are they analyzing
balls going in a hole that's what
they're doing no there's more to it than
that
not really not really it isn't
i am i wrong here they're analyzing a
game
that can be played by children it's not
but it can be understood by a child
that's why children
play sport children don't play war and
peace
they don't play geopolitics
because they don't understand it but
they can understand sports
because it's pretty simple there is a
hoop the ball will now go
in the hoop
is that not what's being analyzed am i
wrong here
is there something deeper than that i
know what the sjw [ __ ]
and the politics everybody wants to you
know pretend but let's be very honest
here
i mean you love golf are you gonna get
mad at me if i say golf is
simple no if i'm writing about it as a
journalist is it relatively simple
no you're whacking a little ball in the
woods tiger woods dad
at four years old said you're going to
be great and he got great i turned her
to the same thing to his
ex-wife tina said you're gonna be great
and she got great
i'm not talking about methods it doesn't
matter i turner didn't say to tina go
out to honey and figure it out on your
own time
he said let's get it moving and what
happened legend
what happened to tiger woods legend but
how complex is this
this isn't the cold war it's golf
it's [ __ ] basketball cut it out
no tim it's you don't like sports you're
gay and gay people don't appreciate
sport
i love that sports the drama the
competition i get it
just don't come around and tell me
people that recap
reality shows are also not bright
am i hurting anyone's feelings when i
say that
people whose main job is to do a recap
of a reality show these are not terribly
intelligent human beings
they're crafty and savvy maybe there's
many of them
all over the place on social media but
the first words
i think of are not intelligence
when somebody's breaking down a scene
that happened on love island or
whatever horror is being delivered to us
there's not a lot of smart people on
this planet
there's not there's a very small there's
a very small group
it is a curse that i'm one of i don't
want to be one of them
i'd rather not be one of them i'd rather
not be one of the smart people
i don't want that i'd rather have a huge
dick and a six-pack and not know
anything but i
am an oracle of wisdom oh no
i didn't know that was gonna happen but
it happened
people get mad at me because uh because
you know they don't they don't think
that i respect their
basketball podcast enough
starvy baby has a basketball podcast
diver i'm sure it's fine mustavi
wouldn't tell you this is a genius level
right because we're talking about sports
which is not complex
it's not that complicated people make it
to be very complete it's not that
complicated
by the way you have a lot of money you
buy the good players some of them get
hurt you got to buy
other ones
ah am i i'm gonna get so much hate for
this but i don't i don't i don't
understand it it it's relatively
we i get it i i love athlete
like i like i i i'm i'm really impressed
by somebody that gets up every day
and puts work into their their ability
to do something
physically i think that is great i'm a
big proponent of that
um but again
are they the brightest people
no no in fact
being dumb is a great asset if you're an
athlete
it is it's so so important mentally yeah
to be
kind of dumb if you're an athlete
if you think you're gonna think your way
out of winning i'm telling you
if you're too intelligent it's a curse
you got to be into the physicality the
body
the the moving around the the just
focus tunnel vision every day
ball hole
you can't be you with your mind it going
in 10 different directions
you can't be a deeply contemplative
person
i think it helps to be
a little dull a little dense
we don't want and that's where you see
athletes they're gorgeous and they're
beautiful we love them we need them
but you don't they're not you know
they're not exactly the smartest people
it's true i'm telling you the truth
you don't want the truth you go
somewhere else just don't get mad at me
i felt bad this little guy got mad
he talks when you know he'll make a
point with sports he gets in a
tone and he's like well what you have to
understand
shut up what are you saying are you on
the team
are you on the team are you making money
from the team
then what are we doing here what i have
to understand
what do i have to understand about the
golden state warriors what do i really
have to understand
what's essential that i understand okay
not much but you can't you can't talk to
somebody who's young and tell them that
i mean it's also like
i've done this rant before i'm not gonna
do it again but
men treat sports like women treat
fashion they all like it they all think
that there's some job in it for them and
in many cases there's not okay
you're not gonna be dave portnoy and
you're not gonna be [ __ ] tory burch
it's just what it is
every [ __ ] girls running around
college going i love fashion i want to
work in fashion
and a lot of guys like i want to be a
sports agent because they like sports
everybody likes sport it's like majoring
in tits
you like [ __ ] too i mean i don't but
it's pretty popular
i mean that's what people like i like
fashion what do you mean you like being
hot right no
fat chick ever says that no grotesque
monster goes
i like [ __ ] on
they don't love fashion hot chicks like
fashion cause they like
looking hot it's not a job i mean it is
a job
melania but the reality is so
people just lose their minds when you
when you tell them
i mean this guy i think he majored in
like exercise science or something
majored in the elliptical
i mean the guy i mean this is a major
now sports medicine and
what toy was sports medicine
what is that jerking off an ex-major
league baseball player
is that what we're doing he majored in
that something
you know i get here's what the hell is
that major here's your knee cream
what are we doing but that's what he
made he majored in uh
fitness and i don't know the philosophy
of the treadmill
weight training you know i don't get
it they studied what proust had to say
about the ketogenic diet
i don't know i'm just saying it's
not a major and you're not intelligent
i get it you're all you're good-looking
i appreciate that and i respect that and
you all have discipline
but don't come at me and get mad at
me for just saying a little bit of truth